Alright. Alright. Welcome back. You know the score.
Rawkode
Academy's
live. We're knocking at your door.
With knowledge bombs and tech that's red hot.
Cloud native AI,
yeah, we've got a lot.
From ours to OCI,
the future's in our sights,
managing models
day and through the night.
Kubernetes
clusters
and registry so grand,
we're
taking AIML,
putting it in your hand.
Today we're diving
deep. No time to delay
stop.
Cloud
native AI,
gonna go the extra mile.
So buckle up, get
ready to learn.
Hello and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
I'm your host, David Flanagan, also known across
the Internet as Rawkode.
In today's session, we're gonna take a look
at running AI ML workloads on Kubernetes and
all of the fun,
interesting aspects of doing so.
There's a lot to learn here today and
we've got two fantastic demos from two fantastic
people from Microsoft. So let's move over there
and meet them now.
Hey, everybody. Hey, Fenman. How are you? Good.
Good. I just have to say to start,
that is probably the coolest intro music that
I've had or I've seen. So props.
Yeah. Well, you know, it's only fitting that
we're doing an AI ML episode. We have
some AI generated music, and I love that
you can just I mean, it's just so
available these days. It's amazing what AI can
do for us. And there's
a lot of cloud infrastructure, CPU, GPUs working
behind the scenes. And hopefully, today, we can
give people a bit of insight on how
to do this correctly, properly, safely. I'm not
sure, but I'm interested to find out.
Could you both please take a moment to
introduce yourself to the audience and share a
little bit about you, please? Sure. I'll go
first. So my name is Josh Stephanie. I
am a senior cloud advocate on the cloud
native team inside Microsoft.
Been in the role a couple years.
Before that, I was, NSRE at Stack Overflow,
and then a DevOps lead in previous roles.
So it it was kind of a good
natural progression and and fit for me, but
I really enjoy enjoy the work and then
kind of, you know, just a little bit
more background on me. Mostly writing Go, but
starting to write in Rust and kind of
float around a lot of CNCF projects and
contribute and do conference talks and stuff like
that. But that's kind of like a a
TLDR on on me. Feynman, over to you.
Yeah.
My name is Feynman. I'm a CNCF project
maintainer and currently maintaining CNCF Notary Project, Auras,
and RADIFY.
Notar project and Auras will be the major
focus today because we're going to share how
to manage and run
AI and machine learning models as OCR artifact
with Auras and also
verify it with notation.
I'm also a product manager for Microsoft
Azure. I have been working
on the secure supply chain over the past
three years, and I enjoy the work
including open source and securing supply chain.
All right, awesome. Thank you both so much.
Let's start off with a couple of questions
and then I will ease into the demo
today. Well, you know, I've been in this
Kubernetes space for a while. AI and ML
workloads are are very new to me.
I'm gonna say running them on Kubernetes does
fill me with a little bit of fear
because when I think of Kubernetes, I think
of stateless services, small containers,
low memory and CPU footprint and been packing
as much stuff into a single machine as
I can.
But everything I know about AI and ML
is,
gigs, terabytes, petabytes of data being shifted about.
I've seen some crazy
container image sizes that I don't even want
to think about.
Is Kubernetes
important in AI and ML workloads? And how
do we make that sensible for people that
are watching?
It's really brave.
Do you wanna take a a stab? I
I can I can take a stab if
you want, Feyman? Yeah. You can. Go ahead.
For for me, it just kinda brings me
back. You know, containers started about that the
image size. You know, if you look if
you look back, like, even the Windows containers,
I know they're not as popular as the
Linux containers, but they they started around that
same that same size. So Kubernetes as as
a platform, so per so to speak, can
handle that type of size.
I think where it's most appealing for me
to use Kubernetes is just the orchestration
and the abstractions that it gives you and
being able to move components around.
So I I would hate to give up
that flexibility of the orchestrator from a deployment
perspective and then being able to have everything
in YAML as much as YAML is a
pain to work with
From that the CICD perspective
and the and the velocity that you can
achieve with those systems,
I think, is still pretty important.
Granted, our image sizes are increasing again, but
it's really not too different from a recent
past,
to be honest.
Alright. Awesome.
Yeah. I mean,
we've already gotten out ten years of expertise
of Kubernetes under our belt. And as we
explore these
new workloads, which are AI and ML based
at the moment, I mean, everything seems to
be going this way, with agentic workflows now.
You know, there is a potential future where
we don't even write software anymore. We're just
writing LLM agents and then having them talk
to each other. Like, I I I don't
know how far away that is, but the
AI buzz would tell us that it's next
week or it was last week and we're
just not. Yeah. It's hard to tell. But,
yeah, I'm very excited for today's session.
Can you both take a minute just to
tell us what you're going to be showing
the audience today and what they're gonna walk
away with? Sure. I'll let Fei Men go
first because he's doing the first demo.
Yeah. Today, we're going to walk through the
challenges of managing AI and machine learning models
in cloud native world, especially on Kubernetes.
And then we're gonna briefly share what is
OCI, the OCI standard, open container initiatives,
and also what is the CNCF ORAAS project.
And next, we're gonna briefly share the Notre
project. I remember we have another fellow, Yi,
who delved into the Notre project and ratified
for signing the verification. But today, we're gonna
demonstrate Notre project in another aspect,
which is sign and verification
of the AI models.
And
we will have two demos today.
The first one is to package and run
AI models as an OCI artifact, and we
can push it to the OCR registry.
And the second demo will be taken by
Josh
to demonstrate
how can you sign and verify your AI
models locally and distribute it
via OSA registries.
All right, awesome.
Well, thank you for sharing. I think it's
about time we share a screen, get hands
on, and show off some pretty cool open
source technologies. So
let's jump over to the screen share.
Alright. Take it away, Venkman.
Awesome. Thank you, David.
So
when we're thinking about managing AI or machine
learning models,
what's the challenges
coming to your mind?
Actually,
not an AI expert. I'm also quite new
to AI, but
what attracts my interest?
Actually,
have seen a lot of customers and community
fellows
who are asking
questions like, hey,
we have a very large size
LM models.
How can we run it in a container?
How can we containerize it and make sure
they can be
stored
in a centralized place, just like OSAT registry?
And how can we distribute it to different
platform and also from dev to production?
And eventually, Devon built a central
platform to host those models and also securely
distribute it from on premise to multi cloud
environment.
That is the questions come from our real
customers and the real world. We have seen
users like Bloomberg,
Red Hat,
and also a lot of end users, they
are trying to
store their AI models in the Container Registry.
That's very magic, right? So previously,
our awareness about the Container Registry is that
we just use it to store container images
and maybe Helm charts, right?
But
with the new standard such as OCR 1.1,
we are able to store
anything in OCR registries,
such as arbitrary files,
supply chain artifacts like SBONG and
signature,
and also maybe even AI models in a
central place, right?
So here's the thing. So we have seen
a lot of customers and industries are complaining
about lack of a
unified standard to manage
and distribute AI models in a cloud native
world. So basically, the lack of the
standard to
make the model management
have versioning and reproducibility
because
AI models is evolving very fast. They may
have multiple versions, but they didn't use Git
and
OCI to manage those versions.
So versioning and the reproducibility
might be the first challenge for the industry.
Second,
as we all know that
the AI models
sometimes have more than
at least one gigabyte, right? It's very large.
So it's a big challenge for them to
distribute it from their local to the remote
securely.
How can they secure the
AI model distribution?
That's another challenge.
And how can they transfer those models from
their local environment to maybe different
cloud platform and eventually running
it on Kubernetes.
Even more, they are thinking about how can
they deploy it
in
an efficient way. So those are the challenges
that we have been observed from the industry
and also from our communication with the customers,
with our communities.
Okay,
so the AI or AI infra, machine learning
infra developers,
they may want to use the same tools
without any change.
They want to have
even minimal change in their workflow to achieve
a unified management
norm in their AI or machine learning
standard,
right?
They want to have easy mode evaluation and
deployment.
Those are the real requirements that we heard
from the communities.
But from
the engineering perspective,
so we may receive the request from
the engineering team that they want to ensure
the software best practice by following the engineering
conventions.
For example, they want to have the model
files management
immutable,
and they want to have very strict versioning
for the model development.
Because in their mind, models are also just
normal software.
There's no big difference between
other software and models.
So they want to have very strict
immusability and versioning,
as well as proper release process and DevOps.
They want to automate everything, right? Because they
are facing a bunch of
pain points to manage thousands of the software
delivery
in the company.
And also they want to make sure the
model distribution
and deployment made the security and the vulnerability
checks and eventually meet the company compliance
criteria.
So that comes to a problem.
Should the ML or AI developers
host those models
on a
separate model registry,
such as OLAMA registry,
or they want to build
an additional
Snowflake.
But from the engineering point of view, they
want to have a unified platform.
Maybe it's an OCR registry.
Maybe
it's an S3
bucket or is a blob storage.
So the thing is too,
people want to unify model
management and
also the model distribution
in a central way.
Okay.
I heard a practice from Bloomberg.
They demonstrated how they currently
manage thousands of AI models in an OSAT
registry
because they noticed
there are several benefits of using OCI registries
as model registry.
First,
they can easily standardize the
packaging process.
So let's say, for example,
they can package the AI models as OCI
artifacts.
With OCI 1.1 standard,
there's
a property artifact type. They can easily define
the type of the AI models and package
it into an OCI artifact,
eventually store the OCI artifact in the Container
Registry.
This should enable consistent distribution across different cloud
environments
because the OCI artifact will be stored in
a central Container Registry.
Then users can pull
the image
or the OCI artifact from the registry and
easily distribute it across different environments.
And also, all of those dependencies
can also be packaged together with the AI
models
in an OCI artifact.
They can be distributed together with the
AI models.
The second benefit is that users can leverage
the registry of efficient storage
because the
Container Registry use
the
content addressable storage
to store
the contained images.
And if you look at the model file
and the
OSAT image, you will find the directory structure
looks quite similar.
I will have another
we will have another picture to showcase
the
structure of between AI models and also the
OCI image.
Obviously, if you have anything in your Container
Registry,
you will have a centralized version control,
and it will be easy to roll back
the OAI model. If you find there's any
vulnerability
or there's any unexpected
change, you can roll back to the last
version.
And you can also reproduce
the change for different environment,
right?
And obviously, you will also have a unified
access control because you can leverage the role
based access control for AI models and container
images in a central place. And you can
also enhance your supply chain security
for your AI models
by attaching signatures,
S bombs, attestations
with the model files in the OCI artifact.
That is the benefits of using OCI Registry
as Model Registry to distribute and store your
AI models.
So go ahead.
So we're going to deep dive
into the OCI standard.
So Josh, would you want to take
it?
Yeah. Of course. And apologies if I went
a little bit darker. It looks like my
my light died, and I don't know where
the cord is to plug it in. So
apologies. But, anyway,
so, yeah, we're gonna take a look at
the OCI specification here and what this looks
like. You might have seen this already.
Most likely, you've kind of inadvertently seen this
in GitHub or whatever your repository looks like,
but you've probably not really taken a close
look
at what the metadata is. And what was
interesting so I don't know. Was probably a
year ago. I just decided to go on
a little programming adventure and figure out, like,
how could I like, what actually makes a
container?
What would I need to do to create
my own, like, Go runtime and and Go
packaging for a container? And I ran into
this layout. I started to use the OCI
and realized why every every registry uses this.
But if we just take a look at
this real quick I don't know if I
have a mark or anything, but I'll just
kind of call it out. But if you
look at it, there's kind of this bigger
frame that you need to look at or
a bucket called the manifest. And inside the
manifest has the config, and then it has
the layers.
And then those layers are actually, in the
case of a container, gonna be the file
system that are gonna be archived and compressed
into a particular layer. And those are all
the layers. So, like, the first time you
build it, you get your one layer. The
next time you build the next one. And
then when it runs a container, it extracts
them all out into a unified file system
that gives you all the files. So, like,
layer two might just have, you know, foo
dot t x t in that layer, and
the rest of it has the operating system,
the root file system. And then the config
is what would be passed to the runtime
to modify that container. So if you had
any kind of runtime constraints,
like like
privilege or CPU limitations,
any of those different things are gonna be
inside the configuration.
And so what the manifest does is it
puts those together in in this metadata layout
here that you see. So you you can
see in here we have the media type
that it's an image manifest,
and that's more of a generic container than
you might think. It's not just for containers.
It's like any OCI artifact can be used
and then bundled in there.
And then each one of those things, each
item in here, the configuration,
which you see that next block down below,
that has a media type of config, but
then it has a digest. So each of
these has a digest. It's just a unique
address
for all that content.
And then if we go down to layers,
that's gonna be what's actually stored in there.
And then annotations are actually what you'd see
in GitHub if you're pushing to, like, GHCR.
You can you can take it with different
stuff. Like, here's gonna be the URL for
the project and all that good stuff. So
that's kinda just like a a quick rundown
of what the OCI specification is. But if
we can adhere to this standard,
then we can push the models to any
registry. We don't need to have a special
models registry for it, and then it can
work straight into all of our clusters or
any of our existing CICD pipelines because we're
using the standard.
So go ahead, Faiman. Go to the next
slide, and I'll I'll dive in a little
bit more.
So I guess I should have waited for
this slide. But if we look at this,
this is a a deeper dive into all
these. So we can see down in the
layers, we're actually replacing.
Instead of using container layers and archiving compressing,
we can actually replace the layers with files
themselves.
So this would this is gonna be a
way how we can take those models and
put them into OCI by using files instead
of the the compressed layers themselves.
And you just see that underneath kind of
like the middle of the screen layers. You
see the media media type there that is
considered a layer, but then its reference is
gonna be the foo dot t x t
and then the bar t x t in
in the end there.
So this is how we can use the
image manifest to not only store container images
with their layers, but also files.
And that'll be more important, later on. Let's
go ahead and move to the next one.
So there's two ways to refer. So this
is a relatively recent,
development in the OCI standard before. It was
just we're gonna push a container. It has
a configuration. It has layers. We're gonna pull
it down,
extract them out so Docker can run it
and other run times can run it. But
with the the supply chain work with, like,
signatures and SBOMs,
it became important to be able to refer
to other artifacts.
So this is a signature. I'm just gonna
push it up to the registry. How do
I know that it ties into this container
image? How do I know it's related? So
referrers,
there's two different ways to refer. There's a
referrer's API, which is newer, and then there's
just a referrer.
And I'll go into both of those. So
we'll we'll go into referrer first. Referrer would
use a subject section, so you can see
that on the right side there, where it
says, okay, here are the subjects that are
referring to this other referring to this image
or this artifact.
And so then you can, with ORAZ Discover
and other tools, you can use those links
because those digests, unique addresses
between things that are pushed to the registry
can now have relationships built. The Referrer's API
lets basically gives you an API endpoint that
you can relate to, and it keeps the
manifest the same. There's no changes to your
actual manifest,
but through the referrer API, you can link
them. And you can see that metadata with
different network calls
to the referrer's API. So that that is
important for my part of the demo that
I'll be doing with the signature, which is
how can we relate
or show relationship between and connect OCI artifacts.
And then for the OCI
artifact format in the model so if we
look at
the container let's see. I'm just trying to
refresh on the slide.
And, Fengmin, if you have more contacts for
the slide,
let me know. But it looks like
yeah. I'll actually let Fengmin take on this
one because I think oh, this is more
relevant. Yeah. Go ahead and and take it
very well. Do you wanna go do
you wanna go this slide?
I'm
trying to recall here. Oh, this is just
the layout. Right? Yeah. So okay. Yes. Absolutely.
So on the top here, we can see
so if we were to pull down this
one makes much more sense to me. Thanks,
Raymond, for switching.
Yeah. I wanna compare. Like, there's actually not
a lot of difference between
the
model registry format and the OCI format. And
if you look at it, the the model
registry is actually using a version of OCI
in in this metadata here. It's just changing
the format how it is, enough that it
is
you can't just take an existing tool for
an OCI registry and use it. But we
can we'll walk through changing that in this
in this talk. But if we look at
the top part,
this would be the equivalent if you were
to point ORAS, the tool we're about to
talk to, and pull down the artifact, and
we're gonna pull down the files that it
has. We're gonna extract it out. So it's
not just some nebulous thing up up in
the registry.
This is actually what would happen if you
pulled it on on the cluster, and it's
gonna extract out and run it. So we
have the container
container decontext v one content,
then we have the blobs. The blobs then
have a SHA, and then inside that SHA
is gonna be the the digest itself minus
the SHA. And so those are gonna be
all the layers of that image. And if
we go into manifests,
there would be the overall manifest
that would have the config and then have
the layers inside of that that bundle it.
And one of those layers in there would
actually be the config JSON as well. And
then Ollama just it's a little bit different.
It actually splits out. It says, here's gonna
be your manifest directory
and for each one, so instead of each
artifact having the manifest with the layers, it
splits it out and says, here is the
manifest, and then here's all the blobs for
all the models. So they're disconnected.
The manifest
that has the configuration for it and then
the actual layer that holds the model
are in separate directories.
So
Okay, back to me. Yep.
So as Josh just shared,
the structure, the directory
structure between
AI model, just like the OLAMA model and
also the OCI image, you will find
they are quite similar because they both use
the content addressable
storage to store the AI models and
the OCI images in
AI model registry and also the OCR registry
respectively.
So why
do not unify them in a central place?
Can I add one thing to this, Feynman?
Do you mind?
Yeah. So it's It just popped in my
head a good analogy. So,
you know, back when containers started, we
there was, you know, big awareness of, like,
don't put your database inside the container image
mounted as a volume. Right?
It because it's it's large. Well, the same
thing's really true with models, and this is
what Fame is kinda setting up here is,
well, what if we could store
the model on the registry? That's cool. We
we talked about that. It could be on
a different place. But how do we get
that and use it inside of our container
image? It's not gonna be pulled down the
same way the container image is. It's to
actually start the thing that's running. But what
if you could take images
or things that are on a registry and
then mount them as volumes just like you
would a database? Because it's too large to
completely replicate and bake into each image.
That's that's exactly what this feature here sets
up. So I'll let Famey take over that,
but I just wanna draw that analogy. Like,
think of it as we had this big
database file that we wanna mount into our
container. We don't wanna bake it in and
copy it everywhere.
How can we leverage volume mounts for that?
And there's actually a new alpha feature
for the and I'll let Feyman take it
away, so I won't stall the thunder. But
go ahead.
That's a good point, Josh. So actually, if
you're looking at the
relatively new Kubernetes version,
for example, Kubernetes v1.31,
you will find there's a brand new feature,
an alpha feature introduced in this release, which
is the OCI image volume.
The Kubernetes community leveraged the benefits of OCI
standard
to make
the OCI image volume as an OCI artifact
so that Kubernetes users can mount
the model
directory, the file directory,
into a container and run it in a
pod.
That is very efficient, right?
And you can also take a look at
the Kubernetes blog post for details and its
use cases.
Looking at their blog post, the major use
case is to resolve the
AI model and machine learning model management
and also make users be able to run
it in
a container.
So how can we achieve that? So basically,
you will need to first push your
AI model files
into a container registry or OCR registry.
So
to achieve this, we will need
an artifact tool
to push your
from
local environment to an OCR registry.
The answer will be ORS. ORS is a
fully functioning
OCR management
tool, and it can be used with any
OCR registries.
Today,
most of the popular Container Registry
has supported
OCI Artifact,
OCI 1.1,
and also can
be compatible with ORAs tool. So that means
you can use ORAs to distribute
any kinds of
arbitrary files and AI models across different registries,
including
Azure Container Registry,
Elastic
AWS ECR,
Docker Hub,
Harbor,
and DOT.
ORIS is also a CNCF sandbox project.
You can use it in your on premise
environment.
And it is also fully OCI standard compliant.
We provide CI command line tools and
libraries in different programming languages.
And also, we have a very strong community
back this project.
And we have the Aura CLI
supported by
Microsoft,
Red Hat, and several
community organizations.
We have Aura's Go, Aura's Python, Aura's.net.
And recently, we have Aura's
Java SDK.
You can go to the Aura's website for
more details. And also, you can install Aura
CLI
via different channels.
Okay, go ahead.
So as we can see, we have a
lot of open source projects and
registries
embrace AURs and OCI artifacts.
So let's say, for example,
Helm has integrated
auras
since they are Helm V2.
And also
a lot of security projects like Falco
and policy
notation.
They leverage ORANS to authenticate with the registries
and also manage OCI artifacts
across container registries and their local file system.
And as I just shared, most of the
popular container
registry
have been compatible with OCI artifacts.
That means you can have very good portability
for your AI models if you install your
AI models in the OSA registries.
So here's the list of installing auras
from different channel.
On Windows, you can use Wingate.
On MacOS, you can just use
Brewing Store Auras.
That is quite
straightforward and
very easy to set up.
Okay. Let's jump to demo. Talking is cheap,
right?
So we can have a live demo right
now. And I also have a
step by step hands on article that can
be shared after
this session.
So this is the hands on
labs
that
I'm going to demonstrate.
As a whole, we will share how to
package
an LIM model. I use Olama model as
a sample
model and package
it as an OCR artifact.
Then I will
use
auras to push
the AI model into an OCI registry.
And next, I create
a PV and PVC to mount the OCI
artifact and some volume into Kubernetes cluster.
This is just the latest alpha feature in
Kubernetes.
And finally, I'm going to deploy
the AI model in your pod and mount
the model from the OCI registry and also
run the AI
model inside the container.
The second demo will cover how to sign
the verified AI models locally and also in
the Container Registry.
So this is the high level
process
for this demo. So let's jump to
the
terminal.
And I'm going to show you the hands
on steps.
Okay,
first of all,
assume you already have the tool to manage
your AI models. Here, I'm using the OLAMA,
one of the most popular
AI model management tool.
So actually, I already have OLAMA
in my local.
And
if I run OLAMA list,
I already have the tiny LAMA model put
in my local file system.
Then I'm going to push these
OLAMA models
into a
OCR registry.
So here,
if you look into the models directory,
you'll find
there are two
directories.
One is blobs. Another one is manifest.
This is the structure that Josh just shared,
which is quite similar to OCI images.
If we dig into the blobs folder,
you'll find it has a bunch of
model layers, which is similar to the OCI
image layers
in the blobs. And if you're looking
at the manifest,
it has a
AI model manifest inside the manifest folder.
So here are
the raw files that
Ollama
client tool can be used to run an
AI model
in a file system, right? So the goal
here is to package
the whole
models folder into
an OCI artifact and store it in a
container, in a container image.
So here we can use Auras tool.
I installed Auras
v1.2.
This is the latest stable version in the
community. So we just need to use Aura's
push command
and specify
which directory you want to package
and push to the remote registry.
So here, we specify
the registry.
I'm just using the ACR as a sample
registry, but you can use any registry
on your demand.
And then you can specify
the target directory you want to package.
So here, as my model is located in
the OLAMA folder,
so I just specify the target directory here.
And you can also specify the artifact type
for your AI model. So here I just
use a sample artifact type here.
So if I
run this command,
I should use
a relative
file path.
So I just specify
V2
and models
because I'm already in the olamas folder.
So here,
OLAS is going to package
the directory into a TAR file
and
make it
containerized
in OCI artifact.
So if we run this command,
ORAS will be
studied,
packaged,
and
archive the folder into an
TAR file and make it as a layer
of an OCR artifact.
It may take some
time to execute the command.
As someone who tried to build that tooling
on their own, I could definitely appreciate
archiving it, zipping it up, creating the metadata
layout for it.
So I'm I'm a big fan of WebRTC
for a number of things, even
WebAssembly components. I actually hooked into that
library as well.
Yeah.
I remember Josh also has a nice demo
to demonstrate how to package WebAssembly modules
as an OCI effect and store it in
OCI registry.
This is similar to how we
distribute and package AI models. So here, you'll
find
the AI model has been packaged
into a TAR file, into a layer of
an OCI artifact. So we can look at
the
registry site.
And you will see there's repository
named Olama TinyLlama.
And if you're looking at the tags, this
is the
tag the V2 is the tag that we
just pushed to the OC registry.
So if we
zoom in and look at the layers,
you'll find there's a specific layer to store
the AI model.
It would just be a cool way to
show off some of that. This is what
I end up doing that keeps me out
of the the browser. I'm I'm a terminal
junkie personally, so I like if I can
get out of away from a browser, I
can. So here, this is the the ORS
command that you can use to to display
your manifest information.
Correct. Yeah. There you go. We can have
the same JSON format on terminal,
and we can use ORS manifest fetch to
fetch
an OCI artifact from the Container Registry.
And it will be the similar view with
the Container Registry portal.
Okay, I think we finished the first step,
which is to push the
AI model as an OCR effect to the
registry.
And then we're
going to create
the persistent volumes
and also a piece of the persistent volume
claim
to mount the AI models
into
a container and run it into a pod.
Here, you will need to
create
two YAML files for your
persistent volumes and persistent volume claim, which is
PV and PVC.
And
to save time, I already created those two
storage
stuffs.
The first one is
all Lama models PV.
Here you have to specify
your volume handle here, which is your
image reference.
We can just paste the image reference from
your Container Registry
and put it into the property
value volume handle here.
And next,
we can create a PVC to consume the
PV.
And here you just need to specify
which PV you want to
consume in this PVC.
And let me show you how it looks
like on my Kubernetes cluster.
So here I have a Olama models PV
created
on my local file system.
And I have a PVC
that consumes this PV.
And looking at the status,
the PVC has been bounded
with the PV. That means we can use
the PVC to
mount the OCI
image volume.
I have also defined
the part for our
AI model.
So here you can just use this piece
of YAML file to craft
your
part.
So here
I have already created this YAML file on
my local. I just need to apply it.
Okay, it might be another folder.
Oh, here.
I just need to apply
this Ollama pod YAML and create this pod
on my Kubernetes cluster. So by default,
the image volume will be mounted
into your specified
path in the container.
So I just need to apply
that part
and among the specified PVN PVC in that
part.
Okay. There might be something broken.
But ideally,
we should
have the AI
model as an artifact running as a part
in our local file system.
Maybe I can troubleshoot later, but there might
be some
configuration
problem here.
Let me check.
Oh, there might be some disconnection
of my Kubernetes API server because my kubectl
is broken. But I
can troubleshoot it later.
So the idea here is to
run the AI model as an OCR artifact
and mount the image,
the OCR image, into an image volume
so that it can be run as a
normal pod in Kubernetes cluster.
And we can use kubectl
sq into
the container
and run the OLAMA list and also OLAMA
run the tiny OLAMA
to use the OLAMA model in your container.
But unfortunately, the demo is broken, and I
will provide a recording
after this session and also share the
script
with all of you.
I will hand it over to
Josh. A question before we move over to
Josh. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Shoot. So
hack the Gibson, great username, by the way,
dropped some of the questions in, you know,
when you use the RRAS commands, you push
the entire model's directory.
Mhmm. I'm assuming it's pushing all the models
that are downloaded into a single OCI artifact,
or does it know that you were trying
to push the tiny LAMMA one? So how
do you work with all models and individual
models when you're using RRAS with the LAMMA?
You would have to so he he got
away with Raymond got away with it because
he'd only downloaded or pulled one model, so
it was only going to compress that. So
that'd be one way. The other way is
you would have to look at the manifest
and link what layers
for each model, and then you'd have to
run separate ORS commands to make sure you're
only pushing the elements
or the layers of the image that you
want to bundle it. So he can more
accurately instead of just models and putting or
he could just put all the models in
there and just, here's the models.
But he would wanna have to pick out
the digests
for those layers and then push them as
tiny llama and whatever the next model would
be. Yeah.
Alright. So I guess the preferred workflow, if
you are doing something like this, is to
pull one image, build the OCI artifact,
clean it up, and then repeat. That would
be the simplest way. The simplest way. Yeah.
Yep. Yeah.
Alright. Awesome. Thank you. And if there are
any more questions from the audience, please feel
free to drop them in the chat. Other
than that, I'll hand over to Josh for
demo two. Alright.
Let me see if I can move this.
Oh, I'll just disappear for a while. My
screen up?
It's
up there. Alright. Awesome. So we'll we'll go
with this one. I couldn't help myself from
trying to get demo magic to work, so
we'll see how well it works for me.
But, yeah, just to to start.
Hey, Famey. Do you mind muting your keyboard
right off? Sure. You got MX Blues? I
think. Could even come up with keyboards on
this stream. That's the problem.
So I I got the HH Keybys, which
is the quietest one I've ever had.
But, anyway, yeah, to set up this one,
what I'm gonna show real quickly is a
new feature from Notation, which is blobs
signing or and verification.
And
to kinda set the stage,
signatures are becoming more and more important. The
the analogy is I actually got this from
Kelsey Hightower's talk before he retired, sadly. I
know he's still around on Blue Sky and
stuff, but I'm not working full time.
But, anyway, he gave a supply chain talk
a couple years ago, and he used this
really great story where,
you know, he he went into a coffee
shop. He found a thumb drive,
and it was labeled,
you know, like, latest
go packages or whatever else that for for
compression or whatever. And so he's like, oh,
well, naturally, I'm just gonna plug that into
my computer,
and I'm like, oh, this is exactly the
source code I need. I'm gonna pull it
over. And he used that analogy to say,
like, we, of course, we would never do
that. We're not gonna take a random thumb
drive from a coffee shop and plug it
into our computer, but we pull down container
images and packages
that way. We don't have any verification. And
so signing is one
one way that's emerging now where we can
actually have some trust with whatever it is.
And so we have container image signing through
notation and other tools like cosign,
but we keep when we're doing these arbitrary
blobs since there isn't a predefined OCI
format and everything for the image quite yet,
and we're just pushing random
bits of you know, random archive or whatever,
can we still use those
signature best practices
and supply chain security on those things? And
the answer is yes. And so that's what
I'm gonna I'm gonna show off today.
So without further ado,
this is the notation.
It should say blob, not blog. That's a
typo. So blob signature.
This is only available in version two, the
alpha. So if you don't have this one,
you won't have the subcommands.
So just to be aware of that.
So first thing, I've I've gotten the model
into
an archive, and I've compressed it. So that's
what this is. And I'm gonna create a
signature for that with notation. That signature will
be local, and then I will use another
command in a second that will connect
them, which is why we preface to talk
with the referrer's
subject. So I've successfully signed it.
And let me just create a new one
here
so we could see it real quick. So
if I do l s here, I have
this signature file now. K?
We'll jump back to the demo.
So now I'm gonna push the model
as
this artifact
of
layers tar, and I'm gonna push it to
my registry.
So now I have the model on my
registry,
and I have a signature locally. But now
I want the registry to have the relationship
between the signature
and the artifact.
So I'm gonna use ORAS attach,
and this is gonna use the referrer's API.
So if we were to look at the
manifest, we're not actually gonna see the relationship.
We actually have to hit the referrer's API
to see the relationship between them. It's not
gonna be in the subject that I talked
about before. That's a separate way to establish
relationships in the registry.
So now it's attached.
Now that it's attached, I'm just gonna use
notation l s, and this is gonna show
us the relationship between the image and the
signature. So we can see here, here's my
model. It's yelling at me because I'm using
the tag and not the the digest because
that's more clear. Tags are mutable, so they
could change.
And so it's wanting me to use,
the immutable one, which would be
the digest. But, anyway, we have the model
here,
and this is the digest here. So that's
another way to reference
the OCI artifacts. And then underneath of that,
I can see that there's this
CNCF notary signature with a different digest. So
that's the digest of the signature itself
being linked to it or referred to it.
So
I'm gonna create a policy, a trustor policy
that will allow me to do verification.
So just to create the signature, I don't
do need to do any of this. But
if you ever wanted to validate the signature,
these are the steps now that you need
to follow.
So I already have it. I'm just gonna
override it locally.
So now I have a policy that states,
okay, it's it's basically setting up what certificate
should I trust for this entity,
for this this policy.
And so I'm gonna this is information from
the certificate that was generated that I used
to sign, and so that needs to match.
The trust store that it was stored in
was the the CA demo.
So now that I have a policy, I'm
gonna just pull down the artifact,
not validate the one that's local because that
one was assigned to someone in the registry.
I'm gonna put it in a downloads folder.
So I'll pull that down,
and then blob verify, give it a policy,
and then I'm gonna point to the signature
and then the path to the thing that
I wanna verify.
And and there we have it. You know,
pretty pretty straightforward. But that's how you can
use the new
notation blob,
not blog, blob, verify and and sign together
to kinda secure your ACM models.
That's it for me for that demo.
Is that the demo,
both demos finished? Yes? Yeah.
Actually,
I just saved myself because
I just
got the problem here and I can
finish my demo.
Oh yeah, over to you.
Good work.
If you could share your screen again, please.
Yeah, sure. Let me do it.
It turns out that live demo is sometimes
not always stable,
But actually,
the Kubernetes cluster is not done. I actually
have a kubectmin to run my local Kubernetes
cluster. I just forgot to switch to the
root user because I
installed it on a root user. The kubectl
only has the
access to if I run it in root
user. So here,
if
the
I
pod YAML file,
and it will create
a new pod,
consume the
OCI image
packaged with the AI model. So here,
as we're looking at
the OLAMA model file, the YAML file,
so we
can see the image
the OCI artifact that we just pushed to
the OCI registry. So we have two versions
here. I use v1.
That is the version that I previously pushed
to the registry. That also turns out that
we can have the versioning control for OCI
artifact
in the OCI registry.
And also, it can apply to
manage the
AI models in the registry.
So here,
if we apply that part and create a
new part,
then we got the
We should have that part
running right now. But as the model file
is relatively large, so it takes some time
to create a new container here.
So ideally,
if the container if the pod is running,
we should be able to
execute into the container of that pod and
run our LAMMA
tiny
LAMMA,
run this model in the container,
and interact with the
AI model.
So here, assume
we already
zoom into the
container,
and we should be able to
interact with the AI model. So who you
are?
It should tell me, hey, I'm an artificial
bot.
Okay. That's it.
Alright.
Awesome. Thank you. So
let's
tackle a couple of questions, and then and
then we'll wrap this up just on the
hour.
I I think ORAS is an absolutely fantastic
tool. Right? I'm seeing it used more and
more. It's almost the factor standard now for,
you know, pushing and pulling the things aren't,
you know, typically container images. I mean, even
to the point, I think anyone watching this
session
is probably already using OCI artifacts, and they
don't even know it. Because if you run
the brew command, all of those packages are
now coming from GitHub's container registry to the
best of my knowledge. Mhmm. So it's just
it's nice to see the OCI standard and
these registries being used for such
non container images cases.
What I'm curious about though is I'm assuming
that people maybe are not as familiar with
the Notary project as they are with OCI
and ORS, at least at the start of
2025. And I think that Notary version one
was always considered quite academic and a difficult
program to use.
You've shown us now that there's Notary V2
currently in alpha one. So my question is,
if I get to it
is the Notary developer experience improving with two
point zero and what is the roadmap like
to get to a GA release of Notary
two?
Just
to correct the branding, actually, we should say
Notary Project
two point zero because we
rebranded the project and we no longer use
the Notary V2 as a brand.
So in terms of the roadmap,
we want to make sure the
block signing feature is stable.
And also going forward,
we will support formatted output.
It will be used to pipe the output
to
the CICD pipelines and also the automation scenarios.
So here, all of the demos are running
in our terminal.
But in production environment,
developers will run
notation or RARS commands in a CICD pipeline
or in scripts. So with the formatted output
support,
developers will be able to pipe the output
and
use it in a CICD pipeline.
So two things. One is to make the
block signing and verification stable
and also
support
formatted output.
One quick note too. The note does
have a GitHub action that works for container
images. If you're worried about signing container images,
you don't need to have some kind of
bash script running
ins inside your workflow anymore. You can just
use an action, and it gives you all
the the features and stuff like that. So
do you have any personal experience? Like, what
were some of the rough edges that you
had in your mind that that you'd like
to see addressed? Maybe they have been. I
don't know.
Yeah. I think the the scriptability
of it was always a major challenge, but
also just, you know, the commands themselves are
quite verbose. You know? I'm assuming there's a
reason you recorded your demo or at least
set up some automation because those commands are
not an easy type, especially. So
I don't think that's necessarily a bad developer
experience,
but it can be quite daunting following along
with tutorials and copying big masses.
Yeah. It it does take a fair amount
of context. Like, okay. Well, what
what
like, the envelope size or or the envelope
itself.
You know? Like, I don't even fully understand
the difference between the two. You know? Like,
I know that there's a difference. I know
that it's changing how the signature is formatted,
but a lot of that gets into cryptography.
So, yeah, maybe, like, some
defaults to shorten the commands would be good.
So you don't need to necessarily what's a
good default for those more verbose
flags?
I think one of the other challenges was
also was key management. You know, people don't
like having to manage root certificates and such
like that. Uh-huh. Yeah.
But, you know, when it comes to to
trust, right, you gotta trust someone. And if
you don't meant those keys, there is no
trust. So Right. I guess what people really
should be doing is is leaning in to
Azure and all the other providers that have
KMS because, you know, these tools are invaluable
for management. This type of support material. I
could definitely see that. Yeah. We're getting getting
notation getting bundled in with a PKI infrastructure.
Right? Like, to use it, you actually have
to have a fairly mature PKI infrastructure, and
that's a big prerequisite
for a lot of people that would be
interested.
Yeah.
One more thing. So actually, Notation is also
working with the Azure Trusted Signing Service to
provide keyless signing experience. That would be That
would be coming soon.
All right. And you're not gonna stack a
date on that, are you? You're just gonna
leave me with the same here. Coming soon.
Do a theater near you. Maybe spring, who
knows? Yeah. I mean, that this definitely is
is addressing some of those challenges, and I
would like to see projects like this get
more uptake because security is often an afterthought.
And I think that is because, you know,
developers have a lot on their plate with
cloud native and Kubernetes in general. Right? They're
already going from, just wanted to write some
code to know I'm responsible for shipping it
and packaging it and distributing it and all
of these things. And the easier and the
more hurdles we can remove to allow people
to use something like Notary and have attestations
and all these things. Would honestly, I I
would love sorry to interrupt, but I would
love where you can just
it's done for you on your push command.
Like, Docker push signed.
You know? Like, how awesome would that be?
Yeah. Work on that, please.
I think that would be absolutely fantastic.
And, you know, it's it's
because you could have this whole integration in
the cluster if we just speak into the
registry and we get these keys and this
key exchange and all this, we can do
it for
OpenID Connect and stuff. I'm sure there's ways
that we can bridge this. But it's all
identifying
challenges and solving them in time. Right? And
I think the cloud native community in general
is is really good at that. We're seeing
so much progress with Kubernetes and all these
other tools.
I only have one more question, and then
I'll leave you both to have any final
thoughts that you guys to share.
We've taken a look at ORAS as well
now, and I love that we can push
anything we want with ORAS.
I'm curious about those type definitions that we
have, the ability to see that this is
an image layer.
This is an OLAMA model.
Who's responsible and controls those definitions? Can I
make them up to ship my
Rawkode
data layer and just type in whatever string
I want, or is there some sort of
OCI spec and registration process? Like, how does
that work? There is predefined
types in the spec that you'll wanna adhere
to. It depends on what you're packaging, but
if you're kind of packaging an arbitrary thing,
you can
you ought to pick, like, a a generic
one, right, like what we do with TAR.
So there's a couple to find. You can
define your own,
but then it's not gonna give any help
to, like, how it should actually be structured.
But you totally can, if there's nothing on
the end, expecting that format to be there.
So, yeah, if you go to the OCI
I think he had a link to it.
But the OCI spec,
the different type definitions, there's a number of
generic ones that you could probably squeeze into,
like, whatever file you're gonna just archive and
zip it.
You could use that
that type like we did in the demo,
or you can create your own if there's
no tooling again, like on the other side
expecting a particular format.
Nice. Awesome.
Yeah. Actually, the
industry is kind of
wanting to standardize
the AI model spec.
There's a working group under CNCF
named
Cloud Native AI Model Spec Group.
We are working with them to define the
standards for package and
managing AI models in Cloud Native world.
Here's the open source repository
with the AI model spec.
Coming soon.
We don't have commitment right now. It's still
in a very stage. Yeah.
Awesome.
I mean, it's just nice to know that
all these things are being on. And in
due course, you know, we're making the cloud
native ecosystem and landscape that a little bit
easier day by day. So, you know, thank
you for your continued commitment and making things
awesome for us. Do you either of you
have any final words to share with the
audience before we wrap this up?
Just always welcome the feedback. Like, even just
your couple notes on notation and the pain
points and where that would be good. So,
yeah, if anybody has any feedback from this
session, things that you'd like to dive you
deeper in or questions,
you know, feel free to reach out to
us. We're both on many different social media
platforms.
So you can you can find us in
all those places. But, yeah, just mainly feedback
if anybody has any. More more than welcome
to take that in.
Alright. And for everyone watching this not live,
all of the links and things that we
have discussed will be in the description soon.
I'm not gonna put time on that very
soon. So go check them out and please
feedback to the projects. The GitHub links will
also be in the show notes below.
Alright. Thank you both so much for taking
time out for your day to join us.
Those are great demos,
revealing aspects of cloud native and ORAZ and
notation
that I think people should just go and
kick the tires on it and try it
out and definitely provide feedback. So thank you
both again, and I I hope you both
have a lovely day and a lovely week.
Thank you. Thanks for having us. Thank you,
everyone.
Bye, all.
Native patterns are sure to please.
Thank
you for watching
R OCI show.
Your support helps Rawkode
Thank
you for watching
Doctor.
KELLY: